[Music]
so the cab come on hello hi here we go
please mr. yang we are yang we're mr.
yang yes all right thank you so much and
we're on the guest do you guys visiting
no we live here I'm an Austrian man
named mr. yang go would you like to
listen some music
no no no music just drive please I'm not
only a driver actually I'm also at BG on
Saturday night look keep hop music
[Music]
okay okay listen buddy there's a bunch
of men chasing us with guns and I need
you to lose them now [ __ ] yeah so much
[Music]
I interest anyone anymore you just me
though right yes of course I trust you
you don't can't good cuz this is not
some fake spy friendship that the
Russians put together dude shut up I
know but did you so that if we don't
deliver this package a lot of people are
gonna die but if we don't do it in the
middle gets Harris attack or something
Oh What did he say to do we've to get it
to a cafe in Vienna Austria Vienna yes
that's what he said okay well why don't
we do that then do what go to Europe
when a bunch of people are trying to
kill us do you want to die having never
been to Europe or do you want to go to
Europe and die having been to Europe why
are those my only two options I think it
looks suspicious if we go through
international security with no luggage
and just a weird trophy right wouldn't
it be more suspicious if we go through
security with a suitcase that's totally
empty except for the weird trophy yes we
need more trophies then that's what
we'll do we'll be the kind of women who
jet off to Vienna with all of our awards
were notable were recognized we have
best grandson yes
don't be nervous people get cup and
they're not comfortable hello are you
new I usually do what's a czar she get
weird if our phones bad guys can track
us even if they're awful right I've
actually known that for a long time I
went to a performing arts camp what that
would Snowden well that's right you used
to date Snowden no no he tried god he
was obsessed with me it was really into
ska when the whole thing was going down
I was like why is no one talking about
the fact that Edward Snowden was really
into stuff commercial yeah yeah
oh I don't know whatever he's gonna
start shooting they all want what you've
got and they'll kill each and every one
of us until they get it
[Music]
somebody totally gets in the corner on
Easter break today I'm 30 years old
I wear a Hawaiian shirt for my boyfriend
dumped me a text
let's set it on fire we just want to
talk about drew Thayer he's your
boyfriend right I'm sorry what I know
you're a spy it's a long story than a
little explain everything to you
forehead some bad people are after me
another after you if we don't deliver
this package you've yet a lot of people
are gonna die you want to die having
never been to Europe or do you want to
go to Europe and die having been to
Europe why are those my only two options
international terrorist group is
planning a series of assassinations a
lot of innocent people could have died
on us recently would you trust us to
help you
it's real and I honestly think I'm shot
you are incredible and I want you to own
it
[Music]
you have a real instinct for this okay
without you and then we both be dead
[Music]
what you're the boss
and yet who have not sacrificed one
ounce of femininity that is the Beyonce
of the government the story of the spy
who dumped me is simple it's - totes PFF
- get wrapped up in an international
espionage adventure my characters not an
action hero we're just your average
girls trying to do these things we need
to find Coral Overstreet looks like
elephant Valley is on the left Morgan
this is a map of the zoo who doesn't
want to go on a road trip through Europe
with Mila Kunis in came the kid I'm so
sorry
Mila and Kate are both incredibly funny
but they're probably the perfect odd
couple I'll tell you anything that you
want to know Audrey shapes between for
boobs Morgan kissed a cousin I didn't
know it's my cousin how you know so much
about her she's my best friend we know
everything about each other their
chemistry was pretty else done hanging
out on the side rehearsals
their dynamic was really endearing which
I think makes its way onto the screen -
I know a lot of horrific stuff has
happened this week but it has been the
best week in my life
we're always in these weird
circumstances and we're like thank God
we like each other it's a flash drive
you have to follow everybody we would
just have a lot of moments of
spontaneous love and friendship
lots of humor lots of crazy action
sequences
[Applause]
Gary Powell was our second unit director
and stunt coordinator he's responsible
for some of the best action sequences
and Casino Royale in the Bourne movies
just wait just wait to see this really
gonna enjoy this film
with semi-professionals we are
professional
don't trust anyone anymore you're just
me though right yes of course I trust
you cuz this is not some fake spy
friendship that the Russians put
together I know you're a spy it's a long
story that a little explain everything
it's in your forehead some bad people
are after me now they're after you if we
don't deliver this package to the end a
lot of people are gonna die
you want to die having never been to
Europe or do you want to go to Europe
and die having been to Europe why are
those my only two options this is really
happening
could you day to the spy terrorist group
is spying a series of assassinations
will you trust us to help you light it
up
have you ever felt so alive
oh Jesus what happened the spy who
dumped me in you - Wow
what you're the boss and yet you have
not sacrificed one ounce of femininity
that is the Beyonce of the government
rated R in theaters August 3rd
[Music]
[Music]
do you know how to drive a stick
I'm so sorry you know how to change it
here what's a gear okay
we just want to talk about your
boyfriend but he dumped me Dhruva CIA
I'm sorry what some bad people are after
me the other after you I don't know
could you dated a spy
I 5
it's a flashdrive you have to swallow it
before they come back there is no
turning back for us
we're semi professionals at this point
professional we are professional
[Music]
I don't like I'll tell you anything you
won't know I've never kept a seeker in
my life
Audrey shaves between her boobs Morgan
flosses with her hair James about
minions just the one minion with the one
eye she googled it on my computer and
now I get a lot of weird ads if we don't
deliver this package TV and a lot of
people are gonna die we're legit spies
now I'm good to take a chance on you two
there's a bunch of men chasing
okay for two badass [ __ ] who saves
the freakin world oh wow you're so
pretty
no everybody likes compliments the Spy
is dumped me radar August 3rd
[Music]